go try the thing you've been debating
and I know for all of you literally the
fundamental reason that you haven't
started posting on social media to do
the thing cuz that's what you would do
we live in24 is because you're genuinely
concerned about the judgment and the
Judgment can come from your mother your
spouse your children these are important
people what about having empathy for
your mom who's always been negative and
has always put you down because I
promise you her mom or dad or both did
the same to her the reason I've been
able to continue to go because I have
empathy and compassion for the people
people that are trying to tear me down
not anger